はい あの 決めつけるのは
そのダンマ けれども主の働きだとおっしゃいましたけど
そのどこは真理であると
お釈迦様が語っているのは全部真理であると決めつけてしまうところが誤解になるのでしょうか
と思います  知らないで決めつけたらそれは無知でしょ
調べたら地球が丸いと決めつけて何が悪いんですかね
事実ですからね だから仏教はみんな決めつけたっても
仏教の方は全然気にもしない
語っているものは真理だと自分で発見したならば
それから別にどうったことないでしょうに
だから仏教さえもただ信仰で
私は仏教を信じているんだぞと言っても
別に大した意味がないんです
仏教を信じていたっても
神様を信じていたっても
どうったことないんです
信じるだけのことだから
だからそういう決めつけは意味がないんです
これ 決めつけるんじゃなくて
結論に達することですよ
我々言ってるのは データを調べて調べて
あ 真理はこういうことですと結論に達するんです
結論に達することと決めつけることはすごく違いますね
いいですか うん 真理は思考の中にはないんじゃないですか
真理は思考の中にはないんだ
真理は思考の中にはないんじゃないですか
うん 思考の中にないと言ったっても
草の束の例えだったら
草の束も真理を語っているんです
だからそういうのは全部自分が作っているものであって
幻想あるいは妄想の類である
だから我々はもう自分を作った世界で生きていますけど
そこを破る 破ったらそこは真理なんです
だからすべて自分の作っている世界というのは妄想なんです
うん それ説明しましたけど
見たと言っても それは自分を作った世界
聞こえたと言ったら それは自分が作った世界でしょ
だから妄想なんです  うん
すべて妄想といった幻想の世界ですね
そこには真理がない  そこから発見するんですね
システムをね  だからそれをその奥に悟りの世界がある
まあ次元を破った 次元を破ったところで悟りなんです
例えば草の束についてのは味は説明できるならば
もう悟っている人なんです
味っていうのはそれも全部自分の妄想
いやいや 味がちゃんと我々の体に変化を引き起こすんだから
だから草を噛んでみたら何か変化を引き起こすんですね
まあその程度でしておかないと話はできないんだからね
だから何か草が持っている性質があるんだと
これは何やと発見するためには主観を破らなくちゃいけない
それはつまんないこと
細かいところでであって
大元の悟りっていうのは全然次元が違うんですから
同じことだと思いますよ
眼耳鼻舌身のプロセス改良することだから
そんなに同じことです
ただ 禅文化ではちょっと文学的に美しく語ろうとしているだけで
私はそれは今日は使ったんですけど
悟りは眼耳鼻舌身のプロセスを解読することで成り立つんです
そうそう だから瞑想すると何やってるんですか？ それは違うと思う
他はどうやって？ 六識以外に何があるんでしょうかと
そこが悟りの世界  だから煩悩はどこに生まれるのかというと
六識の中で生まれるでしょ
それはだからこの六識っていうのは
結局ヴィパッサナーとか
そういう世界 悟りの世界はそれを離れたもっと内にある
そこはもう言葉 一切の言葉
概念を乗り越えてますから
そうやって語れないというか
一切は乗り越えたところやと
それ以上語るなよと お釈迦様は厳しく
もう悟ったらどうでしょうかと言っても
いい加減にしろよと語れないでしょうと
語る世界はすべて幻想の世界なんです
そのお釈迦様が言わないでいるっていうのは
言ったらみんなが妄想とかに走って
そういう  そうそう そういうことです
から言うなって言ってるんですね
まあ言ったら何か幻想を作るんでしょ
本当はそれじゃないということになるんです
うん  そこは語れません
もう語るということは現象です
全ての言語はそこで終わりますよというふうにお釈迦様に言われているんです
言語は虚の虚のものですから
あって曖昧なものですから
言葉は  言語というのは言葉だけではなく
お釈迦様はもっと微妙に考えます
言語っていうのは いわゆる概念を作るところから
言葉でなくても言語ですよ
それは自分が作っているものだから
それぞれ違うわけです
それでも科学的に作れる範囲ってありますからね
ありがとうございます
はい すいません さっきプラーナヤーマでプラーナというのは多分パーリ語でプラーナっていうものだと思うんですけど
長老は前に何か講演会で
プラーナというものは心が作り出した生命エネルギーというふうにおっしゃっているんですけども
それは別な枠の説明でしょうね
普通 瞑想でプラーナっていうのは呼吸のことです
そのやっぱりそのプラーナをこう使って体を整えたりとか
他の人にエネルギーを送って
その体を改善するってことは功徳にはならないです
わかりませんね 笑 まあ人の病気を治してあげることは良い行為だからね
その時点で考えれば功徳ですけどね
それはちょっとややこしいんですよ
事実でなければね まあだから子供に痛いのは痛いのは飛んでいけと言ったところで
子供は泣き止めたんだからいいんじゃないかっていう質問と同じですよ
どうにもわからないんですね
痛いな 飛んでいかなくても
まあ母はバカなことを言ってるんだから
子供はこれが面白くて泣くのを忘れるだけかもしれませんしね
私は自分がすごい1歳ぐらいの時は同じことを言われて
母にね そういうするがすると考えたんです
覚えてますけどね 飛んで別にあるんですけど
でもお母さんかわいそうだからね
あまりにも面白そうに言ってるんだから
じゃあ泣かないことにしますと
笑 やっぱり自分が1歳の時
そんなとんでもないことを考えてたんだから
やっぱりどんな子供もないじゃないかなと思いますけど
そういうことで まあいろんなあれこれとかね
ハンドパワーとかね あれこれやど病気治してあげると治ればありがたいんですけどね
で 人を助ける 正直な素直な目的でやるならば
まあ悪い行為とは言いにくいでしょう
逆にそれが善行為だと私はあまり言いたくはないんです
はい すみません あの肉体があることがで悟りができるというところで
ですから まあいわゆる天界とかですね
無体ない生命とか それはまあそういうのはその結局六道から解脱できないことで
人間に生まれれば解脱のチャンスがある
そういうふうに考えている
うーん それもちょっと複雑ですね
今 理論的なところを言ってるんですね
生命なら意識ぐらいあるんだよと
だけど ミミズにも意識ぐらいはありますね
肉体や感覚もあります
体のね でも目耳鼻はないんでしょうし
でもミミズは修行してくれるかというとね
ちょっと問題でしょうし
しかし 不可能不可能と論理的に言えないんですよ
ミミズに  肉体を持っているから
思考といいますか 思考することで自分の肉体を動かせるので
より他の漢様とか 思考が能力がない人間とかでも
悟りの世界に早く到達することができると
そういうことですね 我々にはちょこちょこと時間でできるようになっているんですね
本当は一番不幸なところにいるんですよ
人間は全部 6も揃ってるんだからね
だから 例えば我々の目で見れば
猫って本当にもう何も問題なく
よく寝るだけでね 楽だなと時々冗談で言ったりもするでしょうに
我々は苦しいんだけど
やっぱりその時点ですごい便利なところもありますね
我々は思考するは 好き勝手に思考を変えるは
もう考えて手足動かしたりするわ
で それで勝手に煩悩が入り込んで問題を起こしたりする
そこでちょこっと修行はできるんですね
それとですね そのいわゆるその解脱の修行に入れば
精進と集中力を保てば最初元気だとお話でしたけど
そのここおられた鈴木さんなんかは 6ヶ月間
結局取らなかった  鈴木さんとかで 6ヶ月間ずっとミャンマーの方で長いこと修行されて
まあやっと最初の段階に入ったとか
本の中にですね 書かれているように
人によってその長い どのくらいの長い期間とかですね
ある意味 いわゆる解脱するのにですね
人によって違うとかいろいろ出てくると思うんですけどね
そのあるいはまあ座禅なんかでも
なんかトンボと入って
すぐその場で何か修行するとか
解脱するとかですね あるいはお釈迦様が 7ヶ月とか 6ヶ月
あるいはもう 1週間でも解脱できるとか
そんなことも書かれている
その解脱できる その期間というのは
そのどういうのによって
あるいはもう全然死んでも解脱できないとか
いろいろあると思うんですが
それはどのように考えるのか
自分がやっててもですね
果たしてすぐ解脱できるかというのがありますよね
うん はい その世界でもやっぱり自我ということはあると問題ですから
まあ因果法則で考えるんですよ
だから今日因果法則のところ入れようと思ったんですけど
まあまあもう難しいしね
だから条件揃ったら結果が出るということで
条件揃ったら瞬時に結果が出る
トンボというのは条件揃ったらもうすぐたちまち結果ということなんですね
だから このマッチがマッチボックスの薬あるところにするでしょうに
だから吸って何分経ったからたって火が出るのかということを考えれば
適当に吸っちゃえば適当な力で瞬間で火が上がるんですよ
それ力入れないでゆっくりゆっくり
もう 40回ぐらい削っちゃうと薬が落ちちゃって
もう火がつかない状態にもなる
我々の修行もそういう感じで
なんかのんびり生半可でもあれこれやっちゃうと
せっかくの薬も落ちちゃって
もう火がつかないってことにする
あるいはやるぞと言って
パッとマッチを薬のところにパッといっちゃうと
すぐ火が上がっちゃうんですよ
時間っていうのはその関係なんです
因条件揃ったらもう悟りという
それはあの執着 悟りたいという執着があると悟れない
あの なんて言うんですかね
無の状態になった時点じゃないと悟れないと思うんですけども
その悟ろうという気持ちがあってやっていると
それは執着ですから 執着があると悟りは開けないと思います
そういうふうな一つの
それも一つの側面であって
悟りたいという意欲は全くなく達するかというと
そうすると心理学的におかしいんですね
何かに挑戦しなきゃ そのところにも進めないということもあります
言っているのは 悟るという気持ちがあって修行するんですけれども
悟る瞬間というものは
悟りたいという執着があると
そういう瞬間は来ない
まあ悟りたいと思うと間違いですから
悟りは知らない人は悟りたいと思ったら悟り達しません
だからその問題は仏教はちゃんと見事に解決しています
悟りたいと思うんじゃなくて
苦しみをなくしたいと思いなさいよと
苦しみは具体的でありますから
この苦しみをなくしたい
乗り越えたいと 苦しみは具体的で現実的
だからそこを乗り越えたいと思う
そうすると次元破ってしまって
もう悟りの境地に達します
悟りたいと思うと悟れないんです
それは欲 おっしゃった通り欲なんです
欲と傲慢ですね だから悟るためにミャンマーの道場に行ったと言ったら
もう見事にそのままで帰るんです
もう何とかしたいと 自分の人生はもうこんなガチャガチャガチャガチャいやあれやこれやとかね
もうもういい加減いいやと思うということで
自分現実的に感じている悩み
苦しみ 煩悩を怨理と言うんですかね
痛ん 痛いというかね そこで悟りに達するんですね
別なわかりやすい例で言えば
部屋を綺麗にする 綺麗にするという風にやると
ちょっと非現実的 汚れたるものは全部捨ててやるそうと思ったら綺麗になってるんです
綺麗にすると言ったら
自分には綺麗なイメージがあるんですよ
そのイメージに近寄ったら終わるんですよ
あ 綺麗になったぞと まだ汚いかもしれませんよ
ですから 汚れたるものは全部捨ててやると思っちゃうと
正しく綺麗になるんです
そういうふうなことで
まあ人によって時間バラバラですよ
はいはい えっと お話の最後の部分のお話の中で
幻覚を引き起こすからくりというお話があったんですけれども
この からくりとは？幻覚をからくりとは何でしょう
どんなものでしょう  うんうん
幻覚を引き起こすからくりを発見すればよいというふうにお話があったんですけども
この幻覚を引き起こすからくりとはどういうものか
これ説明したでしょうに
例えば 物事は瞬間瞬間体に触れてるでしょ
我々はこれをひと塊にして認識するでしょ
それがからくりなんです
竹の盾を持ってきたでしょ
それからくりの説明なんです
はい よくわからないですけど
大体そこは言っても気づかない場合もありますよ
それはそんなに悩まなくてもいいんです
私は堂々ともう言ってますけど
からくりはこんなもんやこんなもんやと言っても
時々気づかないということはあります
それとですね あの悟りに至るにはプロセスを変えるすればよいというふうにおっしゃったんですけども
プロセスの改良というのは
まあ実際 今やっているヴィパッサナー瞑想ということを考えています
それでしょうね だからそこは普通の世間の認識プロセスと全く違うことをやっているでしょ
私は瞑想を教えてよく言うんだから
これ生き物はやることじゃないんだと
よく瞑想もう最近でしたっけ？もう今半年ぐらいからもうよくその言葉を使うんですよ
ヴィパッサナーでやることは
普通の生きている人間がやることじゃないんだと
一つも実況中継自体を見ても普通やらないことでしょ
実況中継で思考をやめると
世界世間はよく考えなさいと言ってるでしょうに
こっちは考えるなよと
だからそれプロセス変えることなんです
で 考えるなよってどこまでかと聞くと
私は答え出しますよ 例えば目を閉じて瞬間で目を開けて壁の方を見てね
目を閉じる それからパッと目を開けてまた閉じる
これ  2 3回繰り返してみる
2 3回繰り返してみると
どれぐらいの時間で壁が見えるのかと私は聞くんです
例えば目は 1 分ぐらい開けておかないと壁が見えないとかね
はありえませんだからね
大体目を開けた瞬間で壁を見えますよ
それで私はあれダメやと
あんた妄想したんだよと
実際は壁は見えないはずなんです
瞬間で取っちゃうと 壁っていうのは妄想です
思考です だからそこまで頑張ってくださいと
すいません もう一つです
今 テーラワーダの方に長老が根本仏教講義の中で苦の連載をこばじめの中からところなんですけども
その時もテーラワーダの繋がりであるんですけども
その中で今これに そういうのをどういう風に読んできているんですけども
なぜ苦は偉大なる真理なのかということで
根本仏教講義をなされているんですけども
今今日のお話の中でも
その 悟りの条件とは苦を乗り越えればいいんだよというふうにおっしゃったんでしたんですけども
それは今 テーラワーダに 2回目にこの苦の講義に関して連載が始まったばかりで
あと何回ぐらいかかるのかわからないんですけれども
今この時にですね そのその話がよく分かりましたので
悟りの条件として苦を乗り越える方法というのはどういうものなんでしょう
どういうものなんでしょうか
ヴィパッサナー瞑想すれば
方法は一つしかないんです
ありがとうございます
とにかく思考を止めるということですよ
すいません はい 今日の講演の内容の質問じゃないんですけど
はいはい  昨日もちょっと質問したんですが
まあ第 1 義的にはやっぱりあの
いわゆるゲラということでだと思うんですが
よく世間的な俗世間的なこともお話されるので
そのことでちょっと時短ですが
いわゆる俗世間的な仕事というのはですね
ある程度自分のやりやすいようなことを
自分の得意なことをやってればいいんだ
大体それがストレスが少なくなってくようなことを言われていますよね
私にもですね いろいろそういう
自分はあまり能力もないこともあって
そういうことを願ってこなかったので
やりやすいような仕事とか
そういうのを選んでやってやってきたんですけど
やっぱりその会社に入るとですね
そういう仕事をやっていても
なんかまた別の仕事に転させられたりですね
とか あるいはこのここの会社がちょっときついからというので
別の会社を選んで入っていても
なんかその会社と最終的に合併してしまってですね
きつい会社になってしまっているとかね
まあ無常の世界になってしまってるんですがね
なんかやっぱり自分がちょうど言われるような生き方をしたいと思っても
無常で 結局なんかやっぱりまたきついような仕事に回されたりですね
なかなかその無常に あんまり独占的なことですから
重要なことと思わないんですけどね
なってしまっているのでね
そうそうそう その辺はちょっとまた応援して
だからね 世界っていうのはそんなもんですね
こちらいくら安全 完璧に安全第一
安全第一だとしたっても
やっぱりどこかで何か起こるっていうことはね
だからできるだけ 例えば車を運転するならば
もう事故ゼロで頑張るぞとは頑張りますけど
誰かアホが来て自分の車にぶつかっちゃうってこともあるでしょうね
で 私は自分と仲良くしている子供がいてね
その子に言ったのは もうお前絶対事故を起こすなよと
もし事故を起こしたならば
それは完璧に相手のせいでなければダメやと許してあげないんだと
そうでなきゃ だから事故をゼロっていうことはありえない
私は知ってます しかし
お前の原因でするなよと
私も事故を何回も起こしたんですけど
もう一つも本人のせいじゃないんです
別のところから誰か来てぶつかったりとかね
ということだから 我々一人一人ではね
まあできるだけは頑張りますけど
だからって完璧にうまくいくっていうことはね
世の中ではありませんね
おっしゃった通りにあの会社嫌やと言って別に行ったところで
完璧じゃ最悪でしょうにね
ちょっといいですか？今のお話は
輪廻転生の あの 今 実感がっていうか
楽なことをやろうと思うと
また繰り返す だから今何かを苦を乗り越えてやるっていうことが
結局は輪廻転生と同じ
輪廻転生への解脱を目指してやるっていうのと
今の仕事をきついことから逃げてやるっていうのは
輪廻転生の世界 また繰り返すという世界に行くわけですから
今の仕事を苦しくても乗り越えない限りはサクラがないという
うん そうですね まあ一応世の中はそういうことで
まあ解脱に達していない限りは
完全に解決という解策という解放ということは成り立たないんです
あのお釈迦様にものすごいお布施した方のアナートピンディカというね
孤独孤児という日本語で言いますけどね
で 王様よりもお布施するんですよ
だから仏教の教えっていうのは
お布施するともう恵まれるという話でしょうね
でもこの人はものすごい貧乏になっちゃったんですよ
お金がなくなって もうすごいひどい目に遭ったんです
だから一番お布施をした人
お釈迦様は在家信者の場合は男性の第 1号にしているんです
でも全財産仏教のためにそれだったらご論理から見れば
もうますます豊かになるはずなんですけど
結局は貧乏になってしまったんですね
でもまた立ち上がったんですけどね
だからその時ある まあ物語ですけど
その信者さんのね 守り神がいて
心配してもう喋ったんだよ
あなたはね 商売しなさいと
今ブッダのことばっかりやってね
だから貧乏になっちゃったんだよ
ないかと言ったら このアナータピンディカさんがブッダにお布施しなさいしてはいけない
やめなさいと言うならば
私にお前は要りませんよと
出て行けと守り神を追い出しちゃったんです
それでこの守り神がすごく困っている
ところがなくなっちゃって
あっちこっちってお願いするんです
もっとクラスの上の神々に
ただ その神々はね あの人には我々喋りませんよと
すごい偉大なる人やと
最終的には帝釈天にお願いしたんで
あのね いくら私であっても
アナータピンディカさんにこうしなさいと言える立場じゃないんだよと
お釈迦様に言ってみたらどうでしょうかと
ということになって その前にあなたね
その人はなんであなたの仕事でしょうと
人が不幸になったならば
その原因を調べて守り神だからね
そうならないようにするのはあなたの仕事でしょうと
だから あの人の財産を元に戻してあげてくださいと
してあげてから お釈迦様にお願いしなさいと
ったら まあまあ 一応借金取った人々は返してくれないことやらね
あっちこっち保管したお金が洪水になったりして
印が消えちゃって どこにあるかわからなくなったとか
そういうぐらいのことでしたけどね
それは戻してあげたんです
で 海に投げ捨てられた財産もまた見つけて
で いろいろ それでお釈迦様のところで
神様がこの守り神がね
私にいるところがないんだから
アナータピンディカさんに言ってくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様がそんないい
あの人をまた住まわせてあげてくださいと
まあお釈迦様が言うならばということで
もう住むようにしてあげたと
そこはわかりやすいエピソードで言っているのは
やっぱり人生はもうどうしても波があることはね
これだけ避けたいと思ったことは必ず起こるんだからね
いや これだけは他何でもいいんだけど
これだけは嫌と これ起こるんですよ
だからまあ輪廻っていうのはそういうもので
生きるっていうことはそういうもので
そこでできるだけこの得点
百点満点は取れないんですけど
まあ仏教はまあせいぜい 45点
50点ぐらいででもまあ頑張ってみましょうというぐらいでね
私は人生はゲームに例えるのはそういうわけなんですよ
このゲームといっても
私は思っているのは この現代のこのパソコンゲームなんですよ
この人間 昔やっていたゲームじゃないんです
で パソコンゲームというのは決して勝てないという風になっているんです
だからまあ一応頑張ってみる
ステージどれぐらいクリアになるのかと
ということで まあ人生も同じくゲームオーバーで終わりますから
まあどれぐらい点数取ったのかとかね
まあ一つのゲームをやってみたんですよ
最終段階までやってみたら
この最後のステップに入っちゃうと
プログラム組んだ人は決して勝てないようにアルゴリズムを書いているんです
で まあ私は素人だからわからないんで
私は計算したのは このゲームに与えている時間帯 15 分なんです
その間でクリアするハードルはもう 100 あるんです
で  97 クリアすれば OK なんです
一人一人ハードルをクリアすると派手に褒めてくれるんですよ
この派手に褒めてくれるために 30 秒かかるんです
では 計算してみてください
間に合わないんですね
それで中いろいろいじってみたんで
この褒めることは要りませんだから
それカットしようと それカットすれば勝てるぞと
これカットできないんです
メインプログラムのメインフレームにこれ入れてるんです
ファーストステップからもそれ入れてるんです
やれやれと それでもその人のちょっと計算の違うところを見て
そこから潜ったらもうゲーム全部クリアしたんです
クリアしたら じゃあ全部クリアしたらどんな風に褒めてくれる？何もないんです
あっけらかんと だって書いてないんで
プログラムは あっけらかんと
本人も考えてなかったんです
誰かここまでやるぞと
ただ元に戻っただけ ネクスト出てくるだけ
それを打ったら元に戻るだけ
最初そうじゃないんで
ステージワンクリアしました
あんたすごいと なんていう人でしょうか
信じられないんだとかね
まあ英語で出ますけど
もうくだらない褒め言葉とか
だったら最初の段階でこう来たらすごく派手に褒めてくれると思ったのに
あっけなく何のこと だから本人が思ったこの計算ではこれは無理だと
だからまあ言いたいのは
やっぱりまあ私はどんなゲームできるわけじゃないんですけど
たまたまシンプルなゲームで
アルゴリズムもすごくシンプルで
まあそれバレただけなんですけど
だからこのプログラムで
まあやっぱりちょっとちょっと別な方向でいけるんだぞと
だから人生も結局はゲームなんですよ
ゲームは敵がないと面白くないんですね
みんな負けちゃいます
仏教勝利っていうのは
解脱に達することを輪廻乗り越えることなんです
勝利者ですね  あまりめげないでね
そんなもんやと思うしかないんです
まあね 先ほどは先ほどのおっしゃった壁を見る時にですね
さっきあの壁を瞬きの間隔を早くして壁を打つと分かったんですが
あの 人間の目というのは
あのある瞬間 ある一点しか見えない
焦点を合わせるとかというのは
まさしくそうですか 左右で
従って何かものが見えるというのは
非常に短い時間の間に近いものですね
その点を繋げて そこで頭の中で合成しているわけですから
極端なことを言うと 人間の目がある一点をある一点に焦点を合わせて
次の一点にまた焦点を移す余裕は
時間的余裕がない これなくてですね
瞬きすれば何も見えないはずなんですけど
あの そういう意味なんです
先ほどおっしゃった壁が存在しないというのは
壁があるというのは妄想であるという
そういうことなんですね
壁はあることはあると思うんですね
ただ 人間の目に壁として認識されるかどうかというのは
認識するのは あの 人間の目が結ぶ線の焦点を合わせる
結ぶ線を非常に速い スピードで一貫して構成してるだけで
ただそれだけのことであって
そのことから瞬きを早くすれば壁が見えるのは妄想であること
壁は妄想であることはわかるだろうと
今おっしゃった意味がよくわからないんですけど
壁は明らかにあると思うんですけど
人間の目に見えるか見えないかは
それは 見えるっていうのは
別に目の点にある一点に目が目の焦点を合わせてある
特定の時間で見えるのを合成するとか見えるっていう
それだけの話ではないでしょうか
うん まあそれだけの話ですけど
あの 合成するときが煩悩生まれるんですよ
だから我々の問題は 煩悩から心を解放して解脱に達することなんですね
心に煩悩が生まれない状況を作ることなんですよ
だから おっしゃる通りにそれだけの話ですよ
問題は 合成した時点で煩悩が生まれるんですね
だから壁が問題じゃないんです
人間に壁で見えるし あのー
蝶々には別なもので見えるし
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
問題は 人間は壁だと見たら
人間には壁 壁にふさわしい煩悩が生まれる
蝶々は あ 安全なところだと
ここで止まってやろうと思っちゃうと
蝶々にとってはもう居心地のいい止まるところであって
それなりの煩悩が生まれるんですね
だから 合成によって煩悩が生まれることが問題です
合成が問題じゃありません
それは目の力によって
耳の力によって 生命はそれぞれ様々です
それが別にいいんです
それで  なんかあの大きな話ですが
悟りとか解脱という言葉を聞くと
意味が湧くようになると思うけど
それは今苦しい状態からどうか行きたいと
どうか逃げ出したいというように見て捉える場合もあるし
しかし まあ生きてる限りそんなことはできないわけで
そうすると今度は  でもまた決めつけた
[笑い] あるいは自分が自分が存在しないと
どうせ確か一つだと思うんだけども
自分が存在しないと本当に考えれば
解脱っていうのは輪廻からその逃げるところだって
ちょっとよくわかんないですけども
悟りっていうのは一体何なんだっていう
どこか行くというとにかくぼやっと考えに
そこは考えても関係あることが悟りじゃないんだから
それは自我という自我がなくなることだと思います
悟りっていうのは 自我というのは
まあ初めて自我というこの自我意識がありますね
それが消えちゃいますよ
では 自我意識というのはそのできないもんじゃないですか
いろんな自我というのは
その合成によって生じる生じるものだと
部分は全体は部分からできているんだけども
どうも仏教の教えだと
うん 例えば車輪があるのかないのかっていう部品に分けて考えると
車輪っていうのはないじゃないかという部分なんですね
だから その要するに 自我というのは
仏教 お釈迦様の教説から言うと
根本成り立たない概念なんじゃない
成り立たない概念だけど
私にはその実感があるということが問題なんですよ
頭で考える 仏教的に考えると成り立たないでしょう
なんですけど 正直なところはやっぱりあるっていうことなんですね
というのは その俺の話で
それはそのヴェーダナですね
それを  ヴェーダナですよ
うん それは自我ではないと
じゃあ瞬間変わるでしょ
ヴェーダナはある  あるでいたっても
それは瞬間瞬間生滅するものです
考えていることは実感ではないということ
ん？ 自分が存在するという実感があるというのは
ヴェーダナは瞬間瞬間考えていると感じているということは
ヴェーダナが実感になるんです
その実感が自我意識に変わるんですね
ヴェーダナの段階で止めておけばいい
ヴェーダナに対して執着を捨てると悟りと呼ぶんです
5時半ですので 少々終わりたいと思います
回向の文 一同この如き大念処経し
会に時の瞑想とヴィパッサナーによって生まれた功徳は
我が身 先祖 祖国 養親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱がありますように
サッビーティヨー ヴィワージャントゥ サッバローゴー ヴィナッサ トゥ マーテー バワットワン テラーヨースティー ディーガー ユコ
ーバワ ババトゥ サッバ マングラントゥ サッバ デヴァタ サッバ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ドッマヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダ スッティ バワントゥテー アビワダナ シーリス ニッチャンワンダパチャイノーチャッタローダンマーワッダンティ
ー アユーアンノー スカンバラン
サーリプッタサーリプッタ
では シューリーター様
今日もありがとうございます